[Music]
it is Halloween we got Dave poroy news
no up local for news Anor grown up local
for news Anor up before alarm bals
coffee power celebrating nearly 40 years
te they said local
four is this Detroit
you bet your ass it's Detroit you have
way bigger problems to deal with that's
why that's why they're going to take it
to the streets yep of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Jason Kor stars is
Leonardo Ronda Walker is rapael wow your
downtown your downtown looks really busy
while you're filming this
Ashley Darnell Blackburn is how they
just use dude [__] stunt doubles for
the chicks yeah yeah
well because they only knew one guy at
the parkour place they they look like
the stunt doubles from I'm going to get
you sucker when it's like the old black
lady and every time there's a fight it's
a Spanish guy with like the same Blue
Dress On just [__] swinging on people
getting thrown into bars and [__] he's
get a huge mustache and he's clearly
Hispanic and then it just cuts back to
the old sassy black lady and she's like
yeah Darnell darn you you have some
pizza on your right there yep that's it
kimio is reporter you know V has a
Virgie has a good point right you guys
have a lot of problems over
there yeah is there is there still white
people in Detroit there's not even
people in Detroit look at the
backgrounds of filing and all I don't
call them people either M
yeah hey Jones also featuring PR man as
the
shredder why would the shredder be on
your team an
Indian yes an Indian why why why is an
Indian on your team
Turtles your turtles who show me old
boms boms from turtles turtles vine okay
I want you please food Clan I want you
to kick in to high gear please whoa guys
Shredder just called me on the phone and
he needs Target gift cards I want you to
bring me back picture of April's [__]
that's the only thing he wants and the
turtles are constantly constantly
fighting shredder to keep April Oak
Neal's nudes out of his hands holy
[Laughter]
cabanga whoa shredders shredders ripping
a bunch of people off posing as WWE
wrestlers and stealing Apple gift cards
that's not cool
bro [__]
you bloody [__] you [__] you bloody
[__] hello this is a shredder from foot
CL I mean I'm sorry Alexa Bliss I need
gift card so I can make I need gas money
to SummerSlam the techn Drone is just a
run down Indian apartment on
Wheels it's one of the trains They Ride
it's on train tracks yeah and that's why
they live in the sewer cuz they can't
tell the difference holy [__] the Techno
the Techno drone is moving and there's
Indians riding the top of it just
hanging on as it's going down the
road oh
[__] K
[Music]
tles [__] the show is so
dumb oh
[__] I got you
Roy
okay just send you a
link okay let me
see oh thank you this will
work she [__] that dog by the way hey
she's a white girl oh yeah you just
[Music]
know
yes
Turtles they swimming [__] just like
[Music]
me it's just like the real Ninja Turtles
except these turtles in a rape
gang go around and get away with it cuz
that's the culture April O'Neal is only
one episode cuz they raped her to death
they [__] raped
healed to death yeah just like Indians
do they no they raped her and then
sentenced her to death yeah for not
being
pure
py April ail [__] heroes in a cast
system [__] dude you guys three of them
are lime green and [__] Michelangelo
it's a little bit
darker they make him sleep
outside
oh [__] they literally just move into a
sewer and go this is nice I like this
they very nice and then they go this is
my
[Laughter]
apartment more [__] in the streets than
in the sewers Splinter's still Japanese
but he's living in India hiding because
he did a bunch of war crimes for Japan
he
did
wari he was
he was just he just went into Korea and
just raped the [__] out of everybody oh
[__] he's hiding in India now Jesus
Christ oh [__] he's teaching the turtles
how to properly rape gang we are now on
the front page oh well that's bad timing
that was perfect timing you show me
April O'Neal's
[__] this is so this is such a dumb
show we're sorry to anybody who's doing
remove cloth open Bob
please
Carlos and the jaos they live in a sewer
it writes itself hello this is shreder
from
Microsoft hello this is John Cena I need
their money please I love to listen to
Apple iTunes I terminated the turtles
policy number
666666 whoa they made April o'o buy a
bunch of steam cards I shouted out him
most loudly
did you throw a b you did you tell a
page from your book yes it was the
training
manual oh look it there's there's backer
no that's just how big the Flies are
here in
[Music]
India God damn it oh [__] guys come on
grow up look it's still better it's
still better than Street [__] sharks
guys world world's next street [__]
sharks
a bunch of hammerheads Clinging On the
train cars we're sorry Rumble we're
really sorry let's hit the reset button
here we something
different India's a big Market we should
be being nice to them what we should be
doing is [__] on those packis oh
[__] those packies you's never going to
take off there but if we get a chunk of
that India market like WWE yeah maybe we
add an Indian to the show like not in
the room because I don't want to have to
smell him but like we get one on Zoom
somebody put up a good point we would
never be able to do that bit on YouTube
never [__] never no sir we need more
Indian representation how about how
about next time our blue host is down
and you have to deal with that we just
bring him on the show oh that'll be
great yeah yeah [__] Patel will come
on and [__] tell me why it's why it
was my fault always your fault my fault
the server wasn't working I love happens
like when when when they were like our
[__] went down and they go well you must
have done something we done anything
touch
anything oh [__] um okay anyway guys
listen we want to apologize to the
Indian people not not for what we did no
but because you have to live in India
yeah and be Indian Jesus Christ oh
that's gross [__] it's like that reminds
me that video that Danny polishuk made
with this drinking the drinking it on
his hand that might be honestly one of
the funniest videos Danny's ever done
and it's so quick and to the
point Danny's a [__]
Lon do we have that a vir can you okay
give me that one again this will top off
the Indian bit with that Danny polish
truck it's like POV and Indian is
pouring you a drink or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah please got it's one of
the funniest videos Danny's ever done
it's like 7 Seconds
long he's a [__] I got I got the link oh
wow that was fast oh [__] Christ this
is one of the funniest Danny po truck
videos there you go you just ordered a
drink in
India do with the sound because there
some it's music that makes it even
funnier you just order to drink in India
please fingers and the smile I love the
smile and he keeps looking at you like
that's good right he's such a [__]
[__] Danny it's the constant looking
up for approval like like he's like a
bartender would do if they were
huh